a particular story or issue examine
what's at stake and where it's heading
in essence we'll take a closer look at
why it matters today
reality TV our shows doing enough to
look after their on-camera stars once
the cameras stopped rolling the recent
death of a guest on the Jeremy Kyle show
served as a timely reminder of that all
sudden fame can take on the contestants
mental health and as love island makes
its much-anticipated return to our
screens the host Caroline Flack has been
forced to defend its reputation over the
deaths of two former contestants well
one person who knows all too well why it
matters is former love island contestant
and emergency doctor Alex George he
joins me now thanks very much for coming
in thank you yourself I gather sought
therapy after your appearance what was
the aftercare like then and did you have
serious doubts about it well for me I
mean it was a big change going from my
life before the show to you know the
whirlwind summer I had and then you know
life post Island and for me I felt that
I needed to kind of debunk and break
down some of the things I'd experienced
and also learn to cope with what life is
like now so I sought for help from my TV
and you know within 24 hours of me
saying look I could do with a little bit
of support I had an appointment but with
the cancer and I continued to have an
therapy to talk about anything's that
bother me so I do think it's important
that we recognize what impact this such
shows can have on the mental health of
the people on the show as well as the
wider audience and I think it's really
good that ITV have made some changes to
kind of make sure we catch people in the
net if you like and protect and help
people I mean but I mean after the two
suicides relating to the contestants of
participants in love Ireland I mean do
you think these programs still have a
place in the television schedule I think
they do have a place and actually you
know I had a fantastic time on Loveline
and I think a lot of the contestants
would say the same there are obviously
aspects to social media things like
trolling and dealing with issues like
that but we do need a bit of support on
and actually we may be sorted up but
maybe you are you know you're a doctor
NHS doctor you you may be better
equipped to deal with the kind of
problems southern fame can bring and the
disappointment that
you know the sudden fame and the loss of
it can can bring it but other people
clearly not so so you know able to do
that more vulnerable I don't know I mean
I had like 200 followers on Instagram
for me I didn't really even know how to
use in the scrum when it came off the
show others may have been more
experienced but it's with the right kind
of help and support and you know the
right selection of people on these shows
I actually think we can cope with it and
actually I myself now a way better
equipped at dealing with trolling and
also managing you know dealing with
people on the street and things compared
to before so yeah with the right support
I think these shows do have a place and
actually they're fun aspirational we get
a great amount of joy by watching people
you know on TV meeting having loved also
people with respect you obsessed with
their kind of looks and physique and
attractiveness is that a good thing for
people to be taking part in a and B for
people to watch and to be may get the
impression that this is how life is
supposed to be well I think actually the
the magic of shows like love Island is
seeing the relationships between people
and their connections you can form with
the most unlikely characters like I'm
about a normal guy I've got very normal
physique and things but I made friends
with like Jack and other people on the
show that I would never have connected
to with on the outside and I have
experiences that I can carry for a
lifetime so I think it's a real positive
side to these shows you just need be
mindful that there is a potential
negative impact and we should plan for
such things and make sure we catch
people and yeah have the right kind of
therapies and aftercare programs to look
after and do you think there is a case
of an issue with viewers as well who see
you project these images and this
lifestyle that people eat watching it
not just participate may feel
dissatisfied with their lives and it may
they may have problems with that now
this is something I do campaign a lot
about and I talk about on my social
media that this Instagram lifestyle this
perfect lifestyle just doesn't exist you
know we're all normal people and I think
it's so important that if you have a big
following if you're an influencer
whatever that means that you honest and
show people what life is really like not
pretending to have you know jetting
around the world or having the perfect
sports cars behind that we
all have the same struggles and I think
we all have a responsibility to be more
honest be more open and give young
people particularly the right messages
from social media yeah I mean just very
briefly 30 seconds I mean there is a
view that oh well people choose to go on
television they you know take the
consequences but television companies
have a duty to protect them from
themselves in some ways I think they do
I think there's a duty of care both I
think part of is yeah you make that
choice you put yourself in that position
but the show knows what happens and I
think different shows will or are able
to at least provide some care and I
think yes there is a responsibility for
any reality TV show to look after the
people that go on it yeah and you don't
regret going on no not to all right Alex
George thanks very much indeed thanks
for coming